Billy Loomis was born in 1978 or 1979 as
the son of Henry Loomis and Nancy Loomis
Henry was once a lawyer for the movie
studio Sunrise Studios but in April 1974
after helping the studio escape from a
lawsuit regarding one of their actresses
going missing on set he left the studio
and moved up north to Woodsboro
California where he met Nancy
unfortunately he could not leave his
scandalous Hollywood Life in the rear
view because after Billy was born he had
an affair with a woman who also fled
Sunrise Studios for a quieter life in
Woodsboro her name was Maureen Prescott
little did he know Maureen was quite a
[ __ ] she had a secret son named Roman
who was secretly watching and
videotaping their broad daylight
Encounters in cheap motels when Billy's
mother found out about the infidelity
she split up with Henry and skip town
leaving behind Billy with his father as
Billy describes himself maternal
abandonment causes serious deviant
behavior however he managed to keep a
respectable public Persona and seems to
be fairly popular in school he had
developed a love of movies perhaps
partially intrigued by his dad's former
career at Sunrise studio and he has a
group of friends who share this passion
with him because because of his
obsession with Cinema and his inability
to cope with abandonment he's an easy
target when he meets Roman sometime in
1994 who is now an up-and-coming music
video director who similarly could not
get over being forgotten by his mom he
showed Billy the footage of Maureen and
Hank having the affair and even helped
him plot his revenge because Roman was a
director looking to get into future
films in the future his ideas for Billy
were very much like something out of a
movie such as having a partner to sell
out in case he got caught and finding
someone to frame for his crimes Billy
chose his easily peer pressured friend
Stu mocker to be as accomplice and
decided to frame the subject of
Maureen's newest Affair cotton weary but
getting his revenge on Maureen was not
enough he also wanted to hurt her
daughter Sydney Prescott Billy is
considered an attractive guy in the high
school social sphere Tatum Riley calls
him Flawless he was destined to have a
flaw I knew he was too
and other girls at the school gossip
about his bubble butts for these reasons
it's not hard for him to get Sydney to
date him and the relationship started
off hot and heavy but that would change
when Billy's plan went into action in
September 1995. one night billions do
stole cotton wear his coat and violated
Maureen before putting an end to her
life one of them left the house wearing
Cotton's coat and made sure to leave in
such a way that Sydney got a vague
glimpse enough to identify the jacket
and nothing else perhaps Billy put the
jacket over his head as he loudly left
while Stu made a quieter escape and hung
low in a hole in the surrounding Woods a
Woods burrow if you will then Billy
planted the jacket in Cotton wear his
car and that was more than enough to get
Sydney to testify against cotton as an
eyewitness but billions do could not
just leave it at that after their
success to learn how Billy took his love
of horror movies too far why he has
facial hair in the poster despite him
never having that in the movie how he
modeled his killings after his favorite
fictional characters and how he was
inspired by a real-life criminal stick
around to the end of this video
[Music]
do you like scary movies good welcome to
Horror history Billy Loomis was named
after two iconic horror movie characters
whose movies defined their generation
from the Boomers there's Sam Loomis
Marion Crane's boyfriend in Psycho
Generation X had Dr Samuel Loomis the
psychiatrist of Michael Myers in
Halloween Billy Loomis would carry the
torch because scream is a Cornerstone
for Generation Y the tradition would be
taken one step further in Billy's
eventual daughter whose name is Samantha
she ends up taking on the last name of
her mother but if she had taken her
father's name she would be yet another
Sam Loomis additionally Billy would
steal elements of both Halloween and
psycho for his own crime spree which
we'll get to Billy is portrayed by Skeet
Ulrich who is clean-shaven for the
entire film despite what the movie
poster would have you believe and he
also wears the shiny leather jacket for
some reason after shooting screams skeet
played a part in the 1997 film As Good
As It Gets for his character Vincent has
facial hair this is when they did the
promotional shots for scream so he
couldn't shave and mess up the
continuity in As Good As It Gets
ironically for skeet scream was As Good
As It Gets career-wise also Photoshop
did exist at this time but they decided
not to use it I guess screenwriter Kevin
Williamson was partially inspired by the
Gainesville Ripper a criminal believed
to have taken eight victims in the
latter half of 1990. other than the fact
that many of the victims were students
there isn't much resemblance to Billy
Loomis but what is similar is the
relationship between the killers and the
media the media was accused of
exploiting Gainesville and creating a
moral panic in order to get more
attention on their story however the
killer was doing it all for media
attention he wanted to be a celebrity
like Ted Bundy even breaking into song
during his eventual trial
I recall the day I first saw you the
media was feeding him with coverage and
he was feeding them with content the
Gainesville Ripper is not the only
criminal we can say this about but he is
the one cited by the writer of screen
the screen franchise has Gail weathers a
tabloid reporter who is Unapologetic
about her motivation for catching the
killer do you know what that could do
for my book sales the aspect of the
media exploiting the crimes as
Entertainment also comes from the
Gainesville Ripper during his trial he
claimed to have multiple personality
disorder and blamed his crimes on one of
the personalities named Gemini this is a
reference to the Gemini killer from The
Exorcist 3 the spirit of a serial killer
who possessed father Karis it was
revealed that Rowling saw The Exorcist 3
while in Gainesville possibly hours
before he began his murder spree
reported Ron word from AP news so that's
where Williamson got the idea for Billy
Loomis to incorporate his love of horror
movie tropes into his plan and he would
do this at nearly every level but before
I unpack that I've got a talk about
Billy's secret girlfriend
[Music]
foreign
Prescott went off without a hitch Sydney
was experiencing post-traumatic stress
which deterred her from getting physical
with her boyfriend in order to keep her
on his hook he pretended to be patient
and understanding with her for nearly a
year after the incident in order to
satisfy his teenage libido he goes
behind Sid's back and gets with a girl
named Christina Carpenter a fellow high
school student who ends up getting
pregnant with Billy's kid Christina has
her own boyfriend at the time who
believed he was the father Billy's
Affair is just like Hank and Maureen's
and his willingness to follow in his
Father's Footsteps despite knowing the
damage it can cause is a testament to
his narcissism Billy would not be around
to see the birth of his daughter because
he and Stu had plans for the anniversary
of Maureen's death in September 1996.
their first Target for that year would
be Stew's ex-girlfriend Casey Becker who
is also a fan of horror movies and
familiar with horror tropes in order to
make their story feel worthy of Cinemas
they take inspiration from popular
slasher villains at the time Leatherface
Jason Voorhees and Michael Myers were
all known for wearing a mask so Billy
and Stu did the same in particular the
events of scream line up most with Hal
Halloween which is Casey's favorite
scary movie in Halloween Michael Myers
wears a randomly selected white mask
that he stole from a hardware store so
Billy and Stu do the same by getting
these father Death Masks which can be
purchased at any Five and Dime Store in
the states they wait outside Casey's
house one night and stumble upon her new
boyfriend Steve orth who's on his way
over so they beat him up tie him up and
hide him away before making a call to
Casey's house
[Music]
all right
foreign
Billy was the caller using a voice
changer device to speak with Casey not
Stu it's Billy's plan and he's
definitely the Wittier of the two I'm
not sure whose phone they might have
used maybe Steve orth had a cell phone
that they stole after abducting him when
Casey picks up he flirts with her at
first then strikes fear into her when he
asks her name
she gets freaked out and starts hanging
up on him each time he calls until he
threatens to gut her like a fish if she
doesn't stay on he watches the house
from his hiding place in front while Stu
Waits out of sight with Steve orth
closer to the back door I feel like the
fact that there are two ghost faces
further supports the through line that
they're creating a horror movie most of
the slashers that inspired them had some
kind of Supernatural element and by
having two people in the same costume
they could give Casey the impression
that Ghostface is teleporting between
the fronts and back of the house the
villain may be ringing the doorbell one
moment and placing Steve on the back
patio the next he challenges Casey to a
game of horror movie trivia but the
second question is a bit misleading
causing Casey to get it wrong and Steve
to be taken out as a result the third
question again plays with the fact that
she doesn't know that there are two of
them he asks what door am I at and when
she refuses to answer they break in and
search the house in my estimation Stu is
the one to stab his ex-girlfriend just
based on her look of understanding but
not surprised after she sees the killer
unmasked together they hang her in a
tree and gut her later that night Billy
stops by Sydney's house and climbs
through her window she makes him hide
from her dad who comes in and explains
when he'll be leaving the next morning
and where he'll be staying out of town
over the weekend This Time Around Billy
is planning to frame Neil for the murder
so overhearing this information is like
striking gold and he remembers it for
later oh close call you tell Sydney
about how he was at home and saw the
Exorcist on TV with all the good stuff
censored for television and it made him
think of their relationship which cooled
off after Mrs Prescott's death it's
significant that he's making an analogy
to The Exorcist because remember the
Gainesville Ripper lifted his story from
a movie in The Exorcist franchise as
well which he supposedly watched right
before going crazy he claims he's not
trying to rush into sleeping together
and as he leaves she asks if he'll
settle for a PG-13 relationship his
words are empty ones but he really only
has himself to blame for Sydney's
hesitancy to get intimate in the wake of
her mom's funeral he secretly does want
to go further with her but only because
it fits into his sick fantasy of living
out a horror movie everyone knows losing
your virginity is a precursor to death
in the horror genre early the next
morning billions do capture Mr Prescott
and hide him away in Stu's house because
his parents are out of town as well they
Park his car in the woods nearby and
also steal his cell phone which they
clone so that each of them can make
calls in order to frame him at school
that day Billy is interrogated by police
just like all Woodsboro high students
and apparently they ask him if he likes
to hunt after class they're all sitting
out in the quad eating grapes and
talking about what happened to Casey and
Billy gets mad at Stu for lacking tact
when he's discussing how she was gutted
it looks like he's standing up for his
squeamish girlfriend but he's really
just playing the part of Innocence that
evening Billy knows Sydney is home alone
having taken care of both of her parents
and hides in her house while she's
sleeping upstairs he calls her using the
Clone cell phone and after asking about
her favorite scary movie it challenges
her to find him which eventually leads
to him and bursting out of her closet
and chasing her up to her room where she
barricades herself despite going after
her with a knife it is possible that he
intended to let her survive this
encounter he doesn't take his chance to
cut her throat and he's almost too
clumsy during the chase plus he still
wanted to take her virginity before
revealing himself as the killer in order
to further humiliate her and he would
have wanted someone at some point to
survive an encounter in order to tell
the tail and Elevate the status of
Ghostface into a horror icon for these
reasons he ditches the costume near her
front door and goes around to climb into
her window and street clothes pretending
to be the concerned boyfriend coming to
the rescue
how would you know that you haven't even
checked the house yet to add further
suspicion he drops his phone and Sydney
immediately makes the connection it
wasn't very common for a teenager to own
a mobile phone at that time though it
was maybe starting to get popular based
on Billy's dialogue at the police
station also why would the killer
abandon his costume before fleeing
unless he was planning to go back and be
someone else it doesn't look too good
for Billy here and he's arrested but
lucky for him his dad was a lawyer and
he begs the sheriff to call him as they
book him Sheriff Burke does call Mr
Loomis so Billy is able to use his one
phone call at the police station to
contact Stu who has the other clone of
Neil Prescott's phone and the other
voice change and instruct him to call
Sydney at the Riley household where
she'll be staying later that night in
the meantime he glares at Sydney through
the interrogation room window taking
advantage of the intimate Small Town
Police Station to try to make her feel
bad for him and deflect suspicion after
a short interrogation they move him to a
holding cell and his dad encourages him
to keep his mouth shut for now
Hank is an entertainment lawyer not a
criminal defense attorney but I'm sure
he has connections however that ends up
not really being necessary because Stu's
Ghost Face called the Sydney works like
a charm nobody suspects they're being
too killer the police also check his
phone records which are clean so he's
released the next morning and even has
time to change his clothes and style his
hair but apparently not wash the
fingerprint ink off of his hands maybe
he just decided to leave that in order
to make Sydney feel bad he runs into her
in the halls and she's still pretty
shaken up he tries way too hard to
convince her of his innocence despite
her confirmation that she no longer
suspects him I know I know the cop said
I scared him away it wasn't me Sid I
know
he called me again last night at Tatum's
house you see
couldn't have been me I was in jail
remember he also chooses this moment as
a really bad time to try to guilt her
into taking their physical relationship
Beyond PG-13 telling her that it's time
to get over her mother's death which
understandably pisses her off
the only reason he tried to put a little
pressure on her here is because they're
only a day away from the one year
anniversary of the Maureen Prescott
murdered so if he's going to take her v
card before taking her L card her life
he's got to do it in the next 40 hours
or so after school we see Stu leave with
Sydney and Tatum but he does kind of go
back towards the school so it's
basically 50 50 on which one of them was
the one to kill principal himbry and
lean over him with the ghost face mask
to watch the wife leave his eyes however
I think it's Billy because of this
detail it's a daytime when Hebrew loses
his life in fact the janitor is still
here so it's probably right after school
too early to hang the body up at the
football field without getting caught
this means he probably had to hide the
body in the office somewhere and go back
later under the fall of knights to put
it on display under the goal post which
by the way is another trait similar to
Michael Myers who like to use his
deceased victims as decorations Stu was
busy hosting his party that night and
Billy doesn't show up until later so I'm
guessing that that was him but before he
would do that he would have to deal with
a fellow student who just knew that
Billy was the Killer
[Music]
billions do touch base again at Bradley
video store which is packed with people
due to a run in the mass murder section
and the fact that people just want to
stock up on entertainment because of the
city-wide curfew set to go into effect
that evening Billy can be seen flirting
with two girls in the horror section
another hint about his unfaithfulness to
Sydney when he hears Randy Meeks yell
out everybody's assistant it's first his
curiosity and he goes over to confront
Randy just in time to hear this spot on
accusation telling you the dad's a red
herring it's Billy
how do we know you're not the two real
killers gang up on Randy and tease him
and although Randy really suspects Billy
he can't prove it shortly before curfew
someone in a ghost face mask stalks
Sydney and Tatum in the convenience
store this was probably Billy because
Stu would likely be setting up for the
party at his house that evening in any
event it seems incredibly risky to just
be wearing the ghost face mask around in
public when the fear of Ghostface is
pretty much the Talk of the Town at this
point thanks to a special report by Gail
weathers we actually don't see Billy's
face again until he shows up at Stu's
party but there is the question of who
kills Tatum who lost her life to a high
quality garage door opener while trying
to escape a ghost face who attacked her
while getting drinks in the garage some
have suggested that this was Billy
because of how he then approaches the
front door from the side as if he had
run out the open garage door and
sprinted around the outside of the house
it's possible but if that is the case he
would have had to go the long way around
the house counterclockwise if he was
coming from the garage it would make
more sense for him to go the short way
around clockwise Plus in order for him
to lactate him into the garage then
sneak in and off her he would have had
to go through the party to to get to the
door that connects the garage to the
house someone would have seen it so I
think it's Stu who briefly stepped out
of the party and killed Tatum while
Billy was taking care of himbree back to
the school plus Stu is the one to make
this suggestion
Stu offers his parents bedroom for
Sydney and Billy to talk and whatever
and Sydney surprisingly agreed so the
two head upstairs with Billy gut
punching his buddy on the way for his
lack of subtlety or perhaps it's a
celebratory smack because their flan is
working so flawlessly upstairs Billy
apologizes for his behavior lately but
to his surprise she's feeling contrite
as well for shutting him out as she
wallowed in grief over the past year he
compares her situation to Jody Foster's
character in Silence of the Lambs having
flashbacks of her dead father the
following interaction explains exactly
how Billy sees their lives
but this is life
this isn't a movie I'm sure they said
it's all a movie it's all one great big
movie
oh you can't pick your genre and with
that Sid accuse him in that she's
finally ready and he plays the part of
the supportive boyfriend making sure
she's ready before they get into it as
they get dressed Sydney asked about who
he made his one phone call to at the
police station and he tells her that he
called his dad which puts her off
slightly because she realizes that
sheriff Burke was the one to call Mr
Loomis I was just thinking if it were
you would be a very clever way to throw
me off track you know using your one
phone call to call me so that I wouldn't
think it was you she seems to only be
joking but again he takes her accusation
way too seriously making him look
guiltier than he would have been what do
I have to do
prove to you that I'm not a killer it
wouldn't take long to find out because
Stu now dressed as Ghostface comes up
behind Billy and butchers him with corn
syrup packets while his back is turned
away from Sid giving the appearance of
real blood from here Billy plays dead
while Stu chases her through the house
and he doesn't emerge again until he
hears Sydney manage the locks do out
pretending to be injured he falls down
the stairs to sell the performance
strangely she doesn't notice that
there's only one cut on his shirt where
he's supposedly been slashed yet there
are two Trails of corn syrup he takes
the gun under the Rouge that he's going
to use it to protect her so when Randy
butts in and claims Stu's gone mad if
Billy reveals himself as the Killer by
quoting Norman Bates from psycho
he also divulges how he used corn syrup
to fake his wounds which he learns from
the prom scene in Carrie like an actor
giving a press interview he's discussing
all of his influences for the movie that
he and Stewart created speaking of whom
Stu appears that the doorway to the
kitchen trapping Sydney in the foyer and
explains the nature of the game she dies
no matter if she wins or loses as for
the rules Sydney has broken one of them
now you no longer a virgin
what
now You Gotta Die those are the rules
the clock rolls past midnight and into
Saturday morning the one year
anniversary of Maureen's death so they
bring out their surprise Sydney's dad
they place the voice changer and phone
back in Neil's pocket to make him look
like the lone killer then they stab each
other so they can make themselves look
like victims later Billy is a little
overzealous when carving Stu's wounds
going a little too deep which starts an
argument between them this may be
Billy's psycho side taking over his body
or it could be intentional now that he
has Sydney where he wants her he doesn't
really care if Stu survives or not
Sydney tells them that they've seen one
too many movies which ties back to the
inspiration taken from the Gainesville
River who many people at the time
believe was influenced by things he had
seen in the media it goes back to the
age-old question does bad behavior in
movies cause bad behavior in real life
this was a Hot Topic in the mid-1990s
scream was released the same year that
the Telecommunications Act of 1996 was
signed in well 1996. it standardized the
v-chip a technology that allowed parents
to block programming based on the TV
rating there's always a scapegoat for
the k parents and man Cairns of the
world to blame instead of actually just
raising your kids with proper values
usually the blame goes towards
whatever's popular at the time if scream
were made in the 1930s it would be
radiant in the 60s it would have been
television in the 80s rock and roll in
the 2000s video games and in the 20s
social media now that I think about it
there was a Scream movie in the 20s and
its villains did cite social media is
Sydney right has Billy Loomis just seen
one too many movies causing him to snap
there have been a number of studies over
the years resulting in an array of
conclusions which was examined by Craig
Anderson PhD director of the center of
study for violence at Iowa State
University he said media violence is
only one of many risk factors for later
aggressive and violent Behavior
furthermore extremely violent Behavior
never occurs when there's only one risk
factor present thus a healthy
well-adjusted person with a few risk
factors is not going to become a school
shooter just because they start playing
a lot of violent video games or watching
a lot of violent movies I guess Billy
was kind of right in a way when he'd
rebutted Sid's clay it don't you blame
the movies movies don't create psychos
movies make psychos more creative the
psychos would run into an issue however
when Stu discovers that the gun is not
where he left it but instead in the red
right hand of Gail Weathers
Billy Loomis now found himself to be the
one staring down the barrel which is
concerning until he realizes that she
has the safety on and giving him the
confidence to drop kick her out of the
house or she's knocked out against a
support beam however before he has a
chance to finish her off he's distracted
by a bigger problem Sydney and her
father have used the distraction to
escape from the kitchen it's strange
that Billy doesn't just pull the trigger
on Gail once the shot is lined up
there's no reason that he can't shoot
her and then still go look for Sydney
and her father it's very much something
that would only happen in the movies and
as we know it's all one great big movie
however his vision goes red when he
realizes he's no longer the lead
character the tables are about to be
turned on him Sydney calls the house and
claims that she's already contacted the
police and stew becomes useless when he
starts to get woozy from all of his Cuts
once again Billy has himself to blame he
throws the phone at stew and loses his
temper as he ransacks the house cutting
up couch cushions to get his rage out
until he gains enough composure to
notice the Halloween movie playing on
the TV as I mentioned and Halloween is
the template for screen and as the main
antagonist Billy is very aware of that
he sees Lori Stroud hiding in the closet
and realizes that Sydney must be doing
the same however before he can act she
strikes first by stabbing him with an
umbrella causing him to drop the knife
and the gun he saved when Stu uses the
last of his energy to bum rush her but
she's able to put him out of commission
in the living room Randy comes back too
so Billy swiftly knocks him back out
with a punch to the face and pins down
Sydney telling her to say hello to her
mother she Jabs a finger into his wound
causing him to scream out and just
before he can thrust his knife down onto
her a recently reawakened Gail weathers
shoots him in the chest I guess I
remember the safety that Tommy bastard
this might have been enough to kill the
normal person but I like to believe that
Billy was so motivated to make his life
a movie that he held on in just a little
bit longer so he could have that one
last scare moment that he had seen in so
many of his favorite films Sydney is
ready for it though and delivers a
headshot to put an ends to the terror
that plagued Woodsboro over the last
year but while the threat of Billy
Loomis may have been gone the horror
would live on early in this video I
described how Billy's name was inspired
by a Halloween character whose name was
inspired by a psycho character this
lineage was intentional Billy was
inspired by horror movies of the past
but now that he'd modeled his life after
a horror movie he would go on to inspire
horror movies of the future and many
people would be exposed to his story
when it was published in Gale weather's
book The Woodsboro murders later that
year the book served as Source material
for a movie stab which came out the
following year in April 1997. Luke
Wilson played the part of Billy Loomis
and he wasn't even more obvious killer
than Skeet Ulrich was in Scream because
in their world stab is a true crime
movie so everyone already knows it's him
around that same time Billy's daughter
Samantha Carpenter would be born and
also around that time his mother would
go undercover as a reporter named
Deborah saltz after gaining 60 pounds
and getting a makeover in order to try
to get revenge on Sydney for killing her
son you killed my son and now I kill you
and I can't think of anything more
rational where the problem is you walked
out on that Sun so I don't really get
why you care now I talked about several
risk factors needing to be Pres in order
to make someone go psycho so I think we
can safely add genetic predisposition to
the list for Billy Mrs Loomis isn't
successful in getting revenge on Sydney
either she seems to have that same
cinematic reluctance to pull the trigger
when she probably should that her son
does mental illness continues to run
down the family to Samantha who has to
take antipsychotics to calm her
disturbing visions of her Father which
started when she first discovered she
was related in December 2010 when she
was 13 years old stab became a huge
franchise leading to many more little
freaks trying to follow in the footsteps
of Billy Loomis at some point in the
2010 Sunrise Studios released a stab
Blu-ray box set which included a special
documentary called stab the true story
where the real Billy Loomis was featured
no you can't actually watch that but
honestly you kind of just did what you
can watch is my comprehensive analysis
on the entire stab franchise just click
on that video on the left remember to
subscribe to cz's world for new Horrors
every week ring the death bell and
select all notifications and I will see
you in the next one assuming we both
survive
foreign
[Music]